In this tutorial we'll cover how to use burp proxy interception rules and all of the associated
options.
Burp proxy is the tool that you can use to intercept, view and modify all the traffic
passing between your browser and the application you're testing.
To see how that works I'm just going to open Burp's embedded browser and visit a URL.
When I do that the requests come through in the proxy intercept view in Burp so that you
can view, modify and forward them.
If you're testing a modern application this can result in a large number of requests and
responses and it can become a bit too much to intercept and view them all and keep having
to click forward.
You can use Burp's interception rules to control exactly what gets intercepted.
We do that in the proxy tool, in the options tab, these settings for intercept client requests
and intercept server responses.
To intercept anything you need to check the box in each section.
By default requests are intercepted, by default responses are not intercepted and you also
need to have your master interception toggle on otherwise everything will get passed through
automatically.
You can define multiple rules to determine what gets intercepted.
Each of these rules can be individually toggled to enable or disable it.
You can have rules set up that you might use from time to time.
You don't have to have them enabled all the time.
The enabled rules are processed in order from top to bottom and the results are combined using
Boolean operators.
And this is a simple left to right logic with no configurable scope.
By default for requests, Burp will intercept requests whose file extension does not match a list of
fairly boring common file extensions for images, style sheets, scripts and other things.
In general, you're less interested in those page resources when you're working.
There are some other rules that are there by default but are not enabled.
So you can say that you will intercept any requests containing parameters or if the HTTP method does
not match the usual get or post, you can enable interception only of items that are in your target
scope.
For responses, the default rule if you enable response interception is that only responses where
the content type header contains the word text will be intercepted.
And there are some other rules which you can use for common purposes.
So if you want to always intercept a response when you modified or intercepted the request,
you can enable these rules.
You can ignore all responses with a 304 status code.
304 status code means to use a local cached copy and this is generally quite a boring response.
And again, you can configure only to intercept responses that are in your target scope.
If you create an interception rule, the way it works is you define the boolean operator that will
be used to combine it with preceding rules and then you pick the attribute that you want to set a rule
for.
So for requests, you have a whole list of different attributes like domain, IP address,
the protocol, method, URL, all these sorts of things.
You can define a rule whether to match on them and you can define does match or does not match
depending on whether you want to intercept.
The match condition can be a regular expression so you've got real flexibility in what kind of items
you match on.
So to see how this works, I'm going to turn interception back on and I'm going to browse
a bit around the Portswiga website.
As we do this, you will see that lots of requests happen.
Some of them are requests for Portswiga.net.
Some of them are for other domains like Google Analytics that we're not as interested in.
So what I'm going to do is create an interception rule that ignores anything that isn't on the
Portswiga.net domain.
So I'll create a rule and use the AND operator and say I want to match on the domain name
and I just want to intercept items that are on the Portswiga.net domain.
I've defined that rule.
It gets enabled by default.
If I now go back to interception and browse around a bit more, you will see that those requests no
longer get intercepted.
So now that we've narrowed down interception just to the domain that we're interested in,
you'll see that quite often as you browse around, you see requests for items that you actually aren't
completely interested in, even if they're on the same domain.
So here we can see we get lots of requests for this bundles URL that contains a lot of
JavaScript bundles that we maybe are not interested in intercepting all the time.
So the way we can deal with that is we can add another interception rule and we can say
I'm going to match on the URL and I want URLs that do not match that URL prefix.
So if I define this rule, it enables it by default.
If I then browse around some more, we can see that requests are intercepted for the web security URL,
but not for that bundles URL, even though those requests are still happening in the background.
So I've defined individual rules for the domain name and the URL.
A different way to do that is to use target scope.
So I'm just going to disable those two rules so they're no longer applicable.
So I'm going to go in in the sitemap and I'm going to add portswigger to scope.
And I'm going to exclude the bundles URL from scope.
So if we look at the scope definition, we can see that portswigger.net is in scope and that
bundles URL prefix is out of scope.
So what we can now do in our proxy options is we can enable this interception rule that was there,
but disabled by default to say that we'll only intercept items when the URL is in target scope.
So if we now browse around some more, we can see this is working.
We get requests for the right URL path and we don't get anything else.
For response interception rules, there are a few additional options that don't apply to requests.
So we can define rules based on whether the request was intercepted or was modified or was annotated
in our proxy testing workflow.
We can intercept based on the status code or the content type header or the mime type or the page title.
So to see how response interception rules work, I'm going to create a rule that says
I will intercept responses only if the request was modified.
And I'm going to turn on interception responses.
So if we browse around some more, we will see that requests are being intercepted in the normal way,
but no responses. And if we edit one of the one of these requests, we then see
that the response gets stalled for interception because it matched on the rule to say that the request
had been modified.
When you're working in the interception view of burp, there are some nice helper functions
that can speed up your work.
Using the context menu or using the action menu at the top, we have some options to define
interception rules.
So we can, on any particular intercepted request, we can say, don't intercept requests to this host,
IP address, file extension or directory.
Or if we want, we can say, do intercept just the response to this one request.
And that will override any of the interception rules that you've got configured.
So that's how to use burp proxy interception rules and all of the associated options.
So that's how to use burp proxy interception rules.